yeah
the 90s weren't so great hey everyone
i'm abby sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by creatures
of habit and we'll be reviewing the
friends diet as popularized by jennifer
aniston courtney cox and lisa kudrow of
the 90s during their heydays of the hit
show friends all thanks to youtuber
jessica vianna who attempted this
herself solidarity girl but first let me
tell you about my sponsor creatures of
habit so i think a lot of us get into
breakfast rats myself included but i try
to make it a priority to get in a
nutritious and energizing breakfast in
the morning even if i don't have a ton
of time to make it from scratch so i
recently discovered creatures of habits
protagonist oatmeal aka superhuman oats
and i gotta say if oatmeal were a marvel
character this would be it
[Music]
it's gluten-free oats mixed with 30
grams of plant-based protein omega-3s
vitamin d3 digestive enzymes and
probiotics so it is a hunger crushing
combo on its own that you can cook up in
mere seconds by adding hot water or milk
or you can prepare it overnight style
throw it into your smoothie or add your
favorite toppings they have four
delicious flavors my favorite right now
is the maple but honestly they are also
amazing so if you're looking for a new
breakfast staple to get yourself out of
your rut and you want to give these a
try check out the link in my description
to get 15 off of your order but also a
huge trigger warning for those with
current or previous experiences with
disordered eating as always skip this
video as we will be discussing
obnoxiously restrictive diets of the
past and also if you're new here don't
forget to subscribe to this channel and
ring that little bell so that you never
miss out on an episode and also follow
me at abby's kitchen over on tick tock
and instagram i want to kick off here by
empathizing with these actresses because
let's be real the 90s were unkind to
women's bodies in general in this video
jessica quotes jennifer aniston saying
that she was told she needed to lose
weight to get the role of rachel and
friends and as gross as that is it also
does not surprise me one bit 90s fashion
and beauty campaigns all glamorize
collar bones ankle bones and other
protrusions aka the heroin chic look
[ __ ] up oh yes it is so let's see what
these three women ate in a day to keep
up with the joneses during the height of
this morbid body trend when she wakes up
she'll make her standard cup of hot
water with a slice of lemon in there i
didn't have
lemon so i put lemon juice it still
counts okay okay so i have no idea what
jennifer aniston's intention was behind
the lemon water in the morning maybe she
just prefers the taste to regular water
and i mean so do i and while a lot of
influencers claims about lemon water are
excuse my french bs it does certainly
have a few advantages over straight up
h2o one it might taste better so it
might be easier for you to meet your
hydration needs and two it contains a
little added vitamin c and other
antioxidants does it help with digestion
maybe
theoretically so we know that bitter
foods like the rind of lemon may help
stimulate the bitter receptors of the
gallbladder pancreas and stomach to help
naturally increase bile flow digestive
enzymes and stomach acids so this is
possibly where this popular claim
originates but unless you're grating a
ton of lemon zest into your water it's
probably not gonna do anything magical
for your gut or regularity beyond what
plain water just always does anyways h2o
if you're adding like a teaspoon of
fresh lemon juice or in this case lemon
juice from a bottle it's probably only
gonna hit benefit a and b so bottom line
water's key for digestion drink it how
you like then
after the lemon water she will go do a
workout of some sort so she will do
30 minutes of spinning followed by 40
minutes yoga and then
she will go to the gym to do strength
training uh
that's intense for breakfast jennifer
says that she has an avocado and egg and
that she sprinkles it with a little bit
of coconut oil so this is very much in
line with all the popular 90s diets
being low carb okay so since this 90
minute workout was done assumedly fasted
we would be looking to get a solid dose
of protein shortly after working out so
probably around 25 to 30 grams of
protein and around 70 to 90 grams of
carbs ideally but instead
jen was consuming 9 grams of protein 13
grams of carbs and barely 400 calories
strike one for why this diet sucks
better yet
the three girlfriends used to have the
same lunch
every day together for 10 years and that
lunch was none other than the gen salad
oh
10 years of eating the same
stupid salad every single day
this is giving me mad kelly ripa vibes
same
three
meals
for a year that's like a whole year
yikes okay a lot of people ask me if
it's okay to have the same meal every
day and to that i would say it really
depends on intention if you eat the same
breakfast every day because of budget
convenience enjoyment and because it
helps prevent constantly thinking about
food all day great i know i have a
handful of meals that i put in rotation
too because my time is limited i know
that i like them and i know that i can
kind of move on autopilot to whip them
up on the fly but if the thought of
changing it up one day triggers anxiety
because you feel out of control not
knowing the calories or the macros or
how your body will react to the unknown
then your routine is not freeing at all
it's restricting and it risks triggering
scarcity mentality and a binge later on
the recipe is one cup of bulgur wheat
cooked in two cups of water and a pinch
of salt two cucumbers i'm going to use a
half a cup of shelled pistachios can of
chickpeas or garbanzo beans half a cup
of feta cheese two tablespoons of
parsley one tablespoon of mint and
that's it voila obviously it tastes
really good because i was really hungry
i mean the only thing that's missing is
maybe some other kind of protein i don't
know okay so this is technically well
balanced you know we've got fiber
protein fat and carbs and that's going
to help to manage physical satiety but
we just want to make sure that the
satisfaction factor is in play as well
and i don't know i would need a little
salad dressing in there to make it worth
my while already cheating a bit i had
some pistachios from the salad during
the afternoon because i was hungry yeah
i don't know how you could not be hungry
then dinner is going to be the same
salad that i had for lunch
i'm sorry that's 7 300 bowls of boring
ass bulgur with no dressing or sauce 7
300 cucumbers and 7 300 cans of
chickpeas like it wouldn't even take
that much creativity to just switch it
up a bit
we could do quinoa instead of bulgur
chicken instead of chickpeas bell pepper
instead of cucumber chev instead of feta
a very diet is ultimately a healthy diet
so even if you're not yet ready to
abandon your magical macronutrient
formula if it's working whatever that
means at least let's try to switch up
the ingredients to improve micronutrient
diversity it's good for your body and
it's good for your gut and your
microbiome as well okay so now let's
move on to monica's day aka courtney cox
so during the 90s courtney was also on
some of the most popular 90s diets like
the blood type diet and the atkins diet
okay before we get into courtney's diet
can we just talk about how problematic
the former fat girl narrative that has
underpinned the whole series really is
like as we established the 90s were such
a gross inappropriate time for female
representation in the media and it's
really shows like friends that
perpetuated that fat phobic undercurrent
that likely drove me and a lot of my
peers down very disordered eating paths
i'll uh i'll see you later okay bye fat
ass all right it's in the morning she
skips breakfast and she has a coffee
instead so it's interesting how we just
kind of repackage and rebrand diets over
the generations what they would have
admitted was a restrictive weight loss
diet in the 90s has really just been
repackaged and called intermittent
fasting for longevity here in 2022. then
her workout routine includes something
interesting she practices budokan
budokan budokan which mixes yoga with
martial arts calisthenics animal
movements and life science then she also
does some cardio like running or hit
high intensity interval training i don't
know who needs to hear this but you do
not need to work out for two hours a day
to be healthy that's all for lunch as we
already know she has the gen salad which
we already had twice oh poor girl like
best case scenario she's eating this
salad daily to not like offend jen worst
case scenario is that she wanted to
conform to the diet standards on set and
research does confirm that pure
influence is greater than the media at
encouraging disordered eating behaviors
amongst women so that's admittedly quite
sad now of course i'm not diagnosing
anyone here but as an fyi i will say
that dietary monotony is a common ed
tactic now trigger warning to skip ahead
if eating discussions are triggering but
not only do we often see a reliance on a
small handful of safe foods that we've
pre-established are unlikely to cause
you to tip the scale but you're also
less likely to overeat something if you
know you're just not particularly
excited to eat it and then for dinner
she has some meat and vegetables so
because i don't eat meat but i eat fish
i will have some salmon instead of the
meat and it will be the same type of
dinner that she would have in terms of
macros and everything
so knowing that low carb reigned in the
diet kingdom in the 90s i'm really not
surprised to see an atkins inspired meal
here but what's kind of confusing is
that we just had like a carb based gen
salad meal earlier so i don't know like
clearly the only name of the game here
is
let's just try to eat as little as
humanly possible which all of you guys
know who watch my videos is a classic
setup for a binge yesterday doing
jennifer's diet i remember i mentioned i
had a banoffee pie in the fridge i did
go and eat it this is what happens when
you restrict yourself and the food you
eat case in point banafi pie
and i mean how could you
not eat that pie banafi pie is
irresistible even when you're not hungry
enough to eat an unseasoned bowl of
bulgur three out of four meals in two
days but yes when we under eat it
triggers a homeostatic pathway that
shifts hormone levels to essentially
force you to eat so never mind pie but
like folks who are under eating will
find themselves binging on something as
unpalatable as undressed bulgur oh yeah
poor jessica
i would eat the whole pie too i'm not
gonna lie during the day i feel really
flat and i feel really fit but that's
mainly because i have literally no food
inside me yeah i think it's really
important to emphasize that this
experience of flatness that so many
wellness influencers chase is not
realistic beyond a moment in time it is
normal like i repeat absolutely normal
for your body to expand and contract
throughout the day as you put food and
drink into it that is not an indicator
of adiposity or even digestive issues
like bloating so please please please
please let's stop pathologizing stomachs
that are not perpetually empty and flat
so at night suddenly like these urges to
just binge and eat everything i have in
the house is literally all i feel which
is not good and it's completely the
normal cycle of people when they go into
these very restrictive diets it's just a
vicious cycle and it's kind of the
perfect recipe for an eating disorder
yep
well at least jessica knows the risks of
what she's attempting to do here we have
ample research that restrictive diets
are the most significant indicator of a
binge or binge eating and it makes
absolute sense so when you under eat
your hunger hormone ghrelin increases
your satiety hormone leptin decreases
your cortisol levels spike up your
unconscious fidgeting and movements
decrease to essentially preserve energy
stores and you obsess over food like
you're never going to see it again
basically because your body thinks it
won't see it again and this is one of
the many reasons why most people who go
on restrictive diets not only gain the
weight back but gain more weight than
they lost so not only will a diet like
this not improve your health but it also
may actually do real harm so according
to courtney she did have trouble
conceiving when she was trying to have
her first child towards the end of
friends she did gain some weight because
she was trying to conceive so as a
fellow infertility warrior i know how
painful it is to feel at fault for your
own infertility and obviously the
tabloids are not courtney's medical
doctors so there could be a
multitude of reasons many of which are
completely out of her control that
contributed to her difficulty conceiving
but we do know that under eating and
disordered eating practices are a common
cause of amenorrhea or oligomenorrhea
which in turn makes it very difficult to
conceive there are a number of potential
reasons for this association and on a
practical level it really does make
sense that the body would essentially
prevent building a new life when it's
working so hard to just sustain yours
but interestingly some evidence has
pointed the finger at our satiety
hormone leptin so leptin is stored in
fat so we see critically low levels in
underweight women for example in
addition to causing extreme hunger when
low it also impacts reproductive
hormones like fsh lh estrogen and
progesterone which in turn prevents
ovulation and menstruation so if you're
struggling with amenorrhea or loss of
periods secondary to an eating disorder
or low body weight check out my video
here for more tips but let's move on to
phoebe's aka lisa kudrow's diet next she
had major body insecurities while
filming the show and that she constantly
compared herself to jen and courtney you
were skinny on purpose um yeah for sure
because you see yourself on tv yeah and
it's that oh my god i'm just a mountain
of a girl i'm already bigger than
courtney and jennifer if i'm eating this
much i look great if i eat less i'll
look better she says she doesn't feel
the need to exercise she said she
realized that if she listens to her body
when it's hungry and what she's angry
for then she could lose weight and keep
it off so this dangerous less is better
attitude is exactly what transforms so
many folks innocent desires for better
health into full-blown eds
trigger trigger trigger
she says she doesn't feel the need to
exercise she said she realized that if
she listens to her body when it's hungry
and what she's angry for then she could
lose weight and keep it off so i like
how the sentiment started and ended but
there's a piece in there that
might not fit for most i think there's a
lot of danger in trying to turn
listening to your body into a tool for
weight loss for a lot of folks
listening to when you're hungry and full
will actually not result in weight loss
especially if you've been restricting
for a long time and are below your
natural set point you might not be able
to even know when you're actually hungry
or if you do know eating when you're
actually hungry may even result in
weight gain so everybody's response to
intuitive eating will vary depending on
their starting point and their body's
needs but what i can tell you is that
when you commit what we generally see is
that it helps one find and maintain
their body's healthiest happiest weight
and prevents further shifts up of that
set point so this is the only thing i
could find about
lisa and her daily diet i know
this is not her daily diet okay diet
recalls are notorious for being wildly
inaccurate but i can only imagine the
pressures of being interviewed as a
hollywood starlet to try to present
yourself as like the fun girl who orders
burgers and a beer while looking like
they only order a salad and seltzer so i
agree we can probably take all of these
accounts with a bit of a grain of salt
she likes a full fried breakfast in the
morning and she says that she really
likes eggs and salami so that's what
we're having i don't eat meat again so i
bought some sort of fake salami deli
meat sort of thing that's made of soy
okay so classic 90s atkins diet aka 2022
keto diet same same but same you know it
the gen salad okay i do appreciate that
taken together we do have some protein
fiber and fat in this kind of breakfast
lunch combo best case here is we combine
the girls meals into a meal so like we
could do jen's avocado uh phoebe's
double egg portion and i guess monica's
coffee's a must and then if i may
perhaps i throw my own name into the hat
as a fourth friends co-star to bring in
a little bread action
reunion in the afternoon i went for a
walk with my friend monica and then for
dinner lisa says that her guilty
pleasure is fried chicken again because
i don't eat meat but i eat fish i just
made some fish and chips okay back we go
to like the pseudo-atkins keto situation
or maybe this meal recall was more of
like an attempt to distance herself from
her uber dieting co-stars i don't know
but in any case if this were real life i
would just recommend adding some kind of
fiber rich vegetable and carb in the mix
to just balance out the saturated fat in
this day this day the whole day was the
only day that i was not super hungry and
i didn't crave a dessert after dinner or
anything yeah like fat protein and
calories are amazing appetite
suppressants and something like fried
chicken obviously seems way more
satisfying than basic grilled meat and
veg when friends first aired these were
the measurements of the three actresses
now for your reference the normal bmi
range is between 18.5 and 25 so at the
time all of them were classified as
underweight so on rachel's day i
ingested
1100 calories and from exercise i burned
close to 400. now on monica's day i
ingested 1000
calories and from exercise i burned over
200. on phoebe's day i ended up
ingesting around
1250 calories which was the highest of
the three there's all these fitness
grows and influencers saying that 1200
calories is plenty and it's the perfect
amount of calories to eat if you want to
lose weight
however dietitians actually say that
1200 calories is not nearly enough 1200
calories is what you would recommend a
toddler would eat yeah so the bottom
line is all of these women were grossly
undereating they were barely meeting
their basal metabolic rate which is the
kind of bare minimum your body needs to
function never mind all of the insane
amounts of exercise they were packing
into their day and as jessica alludes to
later on in this clip eating the caloric
needs of a toddler is associated with
osteoporosis infertility anemia ibs and
a severely suppressed immune system so
yeah it's not a surprise to me that lisa
described herself as being sick all the
time and the other women may have
experienced difficulties conceiving your
body cannot even flirt with the idea of
thriving when it's in survival mode like
this i'm actually shocked that they were
able to come out of the state without
severe metabolic dysregulation but my
guess is that they had like a whole team
to help them reverse diet out of this
which is a process that if you're
interested i have a whole video on right
here so
what can we glean from this unusual 90s
diet well i'm not sure we could call it
like atkins or keto or blood type or
anything necessarily it's just a
straight-up low-calorie crash diet that
was somehow sustained for a decade or
more and that's really disappointing to
me as a former ed warrior because what
the friends women were trying to
accomplish here was the mainstream look
and ideal at the time when i know that i
was struggling but if we learned
anything from this anthropological
experiment and thank you jessica for
taking one for the team here it's that
severe under eating and over exercising
is a recipe for a binge like poor
jessica was feeling the pull after just
one day so you can imagine the damage
done over a more prolonged period of
time bottom line folks do not attempt
this yourself but on that note that is
all that i have for you guys today
thanks again to creatures of habit for
sponsoring if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on who you'd like to see
me review next subscribe to the channel
and i'll see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]